المصادر التي على اساسها تمت
صناعة هذا الفيديو في اول تعليق.
يعتريه الصمت. انفاسه متوقفة
بانتظار قرارات بوتين وردة فعل
الناتو وامريكا. لكن هل على
العالم ان يفعل ذلك? ستجدون جميع
ويقول القوا سلاحكم وسيحل
السلام. لكن هذا اثار الكثير من
بين كوريا الجنوبية وامريكا.
رئيسة الوزراء البريطانية التوجه
الجدل في اسرائيل متهمين لابيد
بانهم يتحدث فقط عن نفسه. فما
نحو تخفيف شروط الهجرة لمعالجة
النقص الحاد في العمالة. العالم
احتجاجات تشرين التي راح ضحيتها
مئات المتظاهرين للمطالبة باصلاح
ان تندلع. بايدن مجددا يثير جدلا
كبيرا بالحديث عن علاقته بفتاة
بتحليلات عسكرية دقيقة. فمن اين
لكم كل هذا ليرد لقد صنعناها
بلاده يديرها اغبياء. ويقول لو
كنت رئيسا ما كان للحرب الروسية
القوة? الاحداث والتطورات. ترامب
يحذر من حرب عالمية ثالثة لان
بالمئة من قواتهم. بينما القوة
الاصلية مرابطة في جبهات القتال.
عراقية للتظاهر في بغداد ومدن
عراقية اخرى بالتزامن مع ذكرى
الاحتجاجات. الحرس الثوري اعتبر
المظاهرات مؤامرة. من جهته اعلن
حشود عسكرية ضخمة وطائرات مسيرة
ومروحيات حربية وصواريخ بعيدة
الاوضاع. رئيس وزراء اسرائيل
يقبل بحل الدولتين في فلسطين
من ثلاثة عقود وبحسب مراقبين
فانها تثير قلق الولايات المتحدة
الجمعية العامة للامم المتحدة
التقى وزير الخارجية الروسي مع
نظرائه في دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وبحث معهم تعزيز
صوب الساحل الشرقي لجارته
الجنوبية قبيل المناورة المشتركة
بشأن مستقبلها مع حليفها
الاستراتيجي في الشرق الاوسط
ايلون ماسك عن تمشيط ستارلينج
بالمنطقة لدعم الايرانيين
العلاقات. واعرب لافروف عن
قناعته بان العلاقات متعددة
الخبراء عسكريون. عرض عسكري
ناقشته قنوات فضائية اسرائيلية
ضرورة وجود مقاربة بين جميع
الاطراف للتوصل الى هدنة مستدامة
فهل سيقبل الحوثيون بتمديد
الهدنة الاممية بعد ان عرضوا هذه
التي تأخذ بالتوسع بين البلدين
هذه الشراكة المتنامية والممتدة
المملكة فلماذا يتمنى الجميع رضا
الخليجيين وعلى رأسهم ولي العهد
ليخرج هنا المبعوث الاممي الى
اليمن هانسج روندبرج ويؤكد على
روسيا حلم بوتين القادم. خطط
بوتين تبدأ لا تنتهي. لنعد
المدى حديثة ومتطورة بحرية
وبرية. فمن هؤلاء يا ترى? نعم هم
وسيتعامل بحزم مع من يعتدي على
امن وسلامة البلاد. فكيف ستكون
منطقة مبررا ضمها. سوف اذكركم
هذه نوفو روسيا اي روسيا الجديدة
والحكومة تتهمهم بالتخريب. هناك
قتل واحد واربعون مدنيا منذ بدء
الشعب والايرانيات خرجن حجابهن
ردا على الشرطة الاخلاقية تفاقمت
بانفسنا حتى ان زعيم الحوثيين
صرح ان هذه القوة هي فقط عشرين
ولكن الغرب لم يأخذ خطاب بوتين
على محمل الجد خصوصا وان نوفو
في صعدة شمال اليمن يظهرون اليوم
للعلن بقوة ضاربة كما وصفها
الذي يجري يا ترى? المجنون
يفعلها. ويطلق صاروخا بالستيا
ذات اثني عشر عاما عندما كان في
الثلاثين من عمره. تستعد قوى
الحوثيون فبعد ان كان عددهم لا
يتجاوز مائتي شخص يعيشون في كوفي
السعودي محمد بن سلمان. الحوثيون
لا يلعبون.
الامريكيون يتعرقون بكثرة.
والسبب تقرب الاعداء من الاصدقاء
عشر بدأ الرئيس الروسي الحديث
بوتيرة متزايدة عن مفهوم اعادة
يغلي. كانت البداية بموت هذه
الفتاة على ايدي الشرطة دار
اوكرانيا يراها القوميون الروس
في روسيا واوكرانيا مناطق روسية
والحلفاء وعلى رغبة الامم
المتحدة. وعلى هامش اجتماع
بالانترنت والرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
يؤكد انه لن يسمح باعمال الشغب
نهاية هذه الاحداث? ما يؤرق
امريكا. القلق يزداد. والمسؤولون
بالزمن للوراء ليس كثيرا بل
قليلا فقط دافعا الفين واربعة
منحها الاتحاد السوفيتي
لاوكرانيا. وقال بوتين في خطابه
نرفض الاتصالات وسنكون دائما على
لقبول الشكل الذي يريح شركائنا.
التطور بنجاح لمصلحة شعوب دولنا.
اما التقارب الصيني والشراكات
فعل ردة فعل. وهنا كشف لافروف عن
ثلاث دول طلبت منه اللقاء واختفت
مباحثات غير علنية معي. قبلت
ذلك. وقلت كما تشاؤون نحن لا
نسمع عنهم شيئا. بعد ذلك. فلماذا
اختفوا بعد ذلك يا ترى? نوفو
ولكن بعد هذا التفاعل بيننا
اختفوا عن شاشات الرادار ولم
الامور. وخرج الوضع عن السيطرة
الامن يعتدي على المتظاهرين
ذلك. قالها وزير الخارجية الروسي
لافروف كما هو قانون نيوتن فلكل
روسيا تضم اوكرانيا ايضا. فهل
يفي بوتين بكلامه؟ بركان ايران
الذي توجه به الى الشعب الروسي
بعد نحو شهر من سيطرة روسيا على
الحق في الحياة وتحقيق السلام
الاقليمي والضمانات والعزم
الاتجاهات بين روسيا ودول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي ستستمر في
الفارون طواعي من ارض المعارك.
السجن بانتظارهم ولمدة تصل لعشر
الروسية يا لها من صدمة عن اي
صدمة تتحدث يا هذا واكد الرئيس
الروسية لمن لديه عقد لمدة عام
للخدمة في الجيش الروسي. يا لها
الاوكراني على خمسة عناصر لصيغة
بلاده للسلام وهي روسيا وحماية
والسجن لاي عسكري يفر من ارض
المعركة. فقوانين بوتين لا ترحم
مستنكرا الفظائع التي ارتكبتها
روسيا في بلاده. فيزياء الحروب.
استفتاء دومبا سوى رد فعل السكان
على كلام سابق للزلنسكي الذي قال
سنوات. بالعودة للمرسوم. فبوتين
امر بتسهيل اجراءات الجنسية
دولتان في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودولة عضو في الناتو طلبت
اوكرانيا بانظمة مضادة للصواريخ
للمساعدة في مواجهة الهجمات
فيه ان من يشعر بانه روسي
فليغادر الى روسيا وها هم يفعلون
بوتين فها هو يصدر مرسوما جديدا.
الجنسية الروسية لمن يقاتل معنا.
احياء روسيا الجديدة او نوفو
روسيا وهي مناطق في شرق وجنوب
العسكرية واستراتيجيتها
وتشريعاتها. اما الرئيس الروسي
ليست حربا عالمية. بعد ان اتخذت
روسيا قرارها واشعلت ثقابها ولم
يحسب عاقبتها نعم نقصد هنا قرار
التعبئة. وعندما سئل وزير خارجية
والهروب من الجيش الحرب يعتبر
خيانة عظمى وعقوبته مغلظة.
روسيا حول قرب اندلاع الحرب
العالمية التالتة هكذا اجاب
لافروف. لن نصدر تنبؤات قاتمة
حول احتمال اندلاع حرب عالمية
لكنه اكد قدرة روسيا التامة على
حماية اراضيها عملا بعقيدتها
الخطوات الروسية جاء بنشر مجلة
ناشيونال انترست الامريكية تقرير
بعنوان تحدثوا الى روسيا قبل
فوات الاوان. المجلة اكدت ان
هكذا قالها الرئيس الاوكراني
وذلك لعدم تزويد اسرائيل
ذلك؟ هل تبقى اوكرانيا في موقف
من لا حول له ولا قوة الا
يعيد هيكلة قيادة جيشه حاليا
ومشيرين الى رفضه طلبات من قادته
للحرب بنفسه ومن غرف القيادة
الروسية. حتى ان قرار ادت لتوتر
من قوانين صارمة. ففي الحرب
القوانين ليس لها صدمة انا مصدوم
الميدانيين للانسحاب من مدينة
خرسون الاستراتيجية. التعبئة
مع قادة جيشه بحسب صحيفة
النيويورك تايمز التي كشفت
لن تكون حبلى بالمفاجآت ولكنها
مليئة بالصخب. الرد الامريكي على
وصفه الغرب بانتكاسة الحرب ها هو
بوتين يضع الخطط الاستراتيجية
كواليس تدخل بوتين في وضع خطط
الحرب لانقاذ الموقف ويضيف
روسيا ستكون الخاسر الرئيسي في
الحرب بغض النظر عما سيحدث بعد
ذلك. من جانبه بوتين فهو لا يأبه
بالتصريحات الامريكية. وبعد ما
الغربيون ان بوتين خلق توترا مع
قادته متناسين ان الرئيس الروسي
عليها روسيا داخل اوكرانيا. اي
يا هذا؟ وكيف سيرد الغرب على
يوم الخميس المقبل حول مشروعات
قوانين لدمج الاجزاء التي تسيطر
وبريطانيا تفتح احضانها وتلغي
القيود? ما الذي يجري في هذا
الصراخ؟ دعونا نرى ما سيحدث خلال
الايام المقبلة التي يبدو انها
العالم يحبس انفاسه. ويترقب هذا
الخطاب التاريخي فعن اي خطاب
يا شاطر. والصين تضم السعودية
الى احضانها. وامريكا تحذر.
العالم? والعوثيون يفجرون مفاجأة
عسكرية من العيار الثقيل والعراق
على شفا كارثة قد تخلف من
الضحايا. قرار بوتين المرتقب.
ها هم يجتمعون اليوم في ارضها.
وكما يقولها المصريون على عينك
نتحدث حيث افادت وكالة تاس
الروسية نبدو ما قد يجري مداولات
الشوارع تغلي والرئيس يحذر. وبعد
ان حاولت الامم المتحدة تفريقهم.
عرضا للفلسطينيين وصفته بالمغري.
فهل يقبله الفلسطينيون والعرب
بينما ترامب عن هذا السر المرعب
المجنون يفعلها واسرائيل تقدم
سادة? العالم يترقب الخطاب في
صمت مطبق. فما الذي سيعلن عنه
الرئيسي. هكذا يتحدث الامريكان
لكن مهلا لماذا كل هذا الصراخ يا
هناك? وهكذا صدمت اسرائيل الرئيس
الاوكراني والروس يدخلون خط
شكرا لكم.
ترى? بوتين يرد ولكن هذه المرة
من ارض الحدث. ما الذي يجري يا
المعركة المنتظرة بين امريكا
والصين بهذا التصريح. وفي ايران
تحدثوا الى روسيا قبل فوات
الاوان. لان روسيا ستكون الخاسر